this is I astark in Game of Thrones
Season one in season three in season
five what happened and what will happen
next let's work it out
Eyre is the daughter of Ned Stark and
Catelyn Tully at the start of the series
she's a scrawny little nine year old
girl and a bit of a wild child fierce
and willful while her older sister Sansa
plays the part of a lady dressing nicely
speaking politely learning to sew and
sing
aya likes to fight and ride and explore
she doesn't want to be the highborn lady
she's supposed to be so she never seems
to fit a bit like John Snow who she has
a close relationship with John gives aya
her little sword needle before going
away to the wall aya also loves her
direwolf
Nymeria but has to send her away after
an incident with Joffrey which also
leads to the death of Sansa's dire wolf
under the orders of Queen Cersei and the
death of Aya's friend Micah at the hands
of the Hound filling aya with guilt and
great anger and hate at King's Landing
Syrio Forel teaches aya to fight and to
be strong perceptive agile quick and
fearless so i a-train's chases cats over
here's a very interesting chat and
eventually everything starts going wrong
again
King Robert dies Lannisters kill Starks
and Serio seemingly sacrifices himself
to save Arya aya kills a boy on the way
out of the red keep then lives rough in
King's Landing until she witnesses with
the death of Ned Stark so in the first
book and season of Game of Thrones I as
friend her teacher and her father are
all killed
she's separated from her family her
direwolf and her life as a highborn all
her grief becomes hatred for the people
who caused these things she wants them
dead but his power will is to do
anything against them for now
ayuh tries to return to the north with a
group of knights watch recruits she
assumes the identity of a boy named ari
and makes friends with Gendry hot pie
and Lommy but the group is attacked by
armory launch forcing aya and her
friends to fight and flee on the way.i
of freeze the mysterious jaqen H'ghar
iron KOA captured by gregor clegane
Lommy is killed and they're taken to
Harrenhal IOC's horrible things at
Harrenhal murder torture rape she meets
many of the worst people in Westeros
armory Lord Gregor Clegane the brave
companions Tywin Lannister Roose Bolton
aya starts to lose touch with her
identity induction to Harrenhal is like
joining the military or a cult
she's stripped and scrubbed and has her
hair cut has the pride in defiance
beaten out of her and is worked hard to
survive in Harrenhal she can't be wild
aya or fear sorry she becomes a grey
mouse girl called weasel keeping to the
crannies and crevices of the castle when
Riss bolton takes arenal she takes the
name Nymeria or nan and thinks she's not
even herself anymore one of the few
things connecting her to our identity as
aya is her hatred for the people she
wants dead she thinks about them as she
works lists them in her prayer before
sleep constantly Birds on killing and
hate Jack and Hagar turns up and tells
aya that since she saved him and his
companions he owes a sort of death debt
so he kills people for her this makes
our brave again a ghost instead of a
mouse when jaqen leaves he gives her a
coin and the words of Valar morghulis
all men must die aya escapes Harrenhal
with hot pie and Gendry killing a guard
on the way out so in this book ru moves
closer to violence and hate and begins
to separate from her identity at the
start of book in season 3 aya is free
from the horrors of Harrenhal she writes
for river room to find Robb and Catelyn
but she's captured by the Brotherhood
without banners an outlaw group
ostensibly fighting to defend the realm
she sees the trial of the Hound and the
resurrection of beric Dondarrion and the
the Brotherhood promised to take ia to
her mother that never ends up happening
hot pie starts work at an inn and Gendry
joins the Brotherhood leaving are you
feeling abandoned and betrayed she wants
people she can trust a family what she
calls a pack and she doesn't find it
with the Brotherhood so she runs away
and is caught by the Hound Sandor
Clegane the hound takes her across the
river lands trying and failing to ransom
her off they kill phrase and Lannister's
together and develop this wonderful
complicated friendship aya hates the
Hound for killing Micah and goes on and
on about how she's gonna kill him or run
away but she never does even though she
gets lots of opportunities The Hound
says he only keeps iya around so he can
sell her off but even after that fails
and she's not worth anything to him
anymore he stays with her why aya and
the Hound are very very similar
they're both suffered both been forced
to serve terrible men doing terrible
things both feel betrayed by their
siblings they're both cynical and angry
and hateful they hate Joffrey they hate
Cersei they hate Gregor they hate
cowards they hate liars they're both
used literal disguises that hide their
faces and they use symbolic disguises in
that they both act tough threatening
people boasting about killing acting
like they need no-one and killing makes
them happy when in truth they are afraid
they feel pain they cry they have no
families to speak of no homes nowhere to
go they say they don't care about each
other but clearly they do they have no
one else so when I refuse to give Sandor
the gift of mercy maybe that was spite
for killing mica but maybe Arya couldn't
bring herself to kill her only friend
anyway with no one and no reason left to
stay in Westeros aya sails to Braavos
clinging to the last thing she has left
her will to kill the people in her
prayer
in Braavos aya uses Jackson's coin to
join the faceless men a cult of
assassins who worship death to truly
become a faceless man aya must let go of
her identity of her hopes and dreams her
loves and hates of all that makes her
who she is
aya must become no.1 Arya works sweeping
floors and cleaning corpses under the
name of cat she spends time in the city
learning the language and the faceless
men teach her to lie she's later made
blind and given the name Beth in the
books not so much as a punishment as
part of her training to develop all her
senses after her sight is restored she's
taken to the Hall of faces which the
faceless men use to assume false
identities higher becomes the ugly
little girl and mercy is ordered to kill
an insurance man which she does in the
books but she also kills some targets of
her own she kills Darion a night's
watchman who's breaking his vows and
kills wrath the sweetling one of gregor
clegane x' men from a list in the show
it's Meryn Trant instead by the kill is
similar so that's our story so far in
these first five books and seasons she's
gone from a sweet kid to a vicious
assassin she's lost everything her
family her friends and her sense of self
what will happen next
where can she go from here she'll
obviously probably be doing some killing
and the people on her list are the
obvious targets but they're all down
south involved in other stuff
where are you really wants to go is
north to the wall to Jon aya and John
think of each other all the time
I only goes to Braavos because the ship
can take her to Jon and much of John's
story in dance is about aya the plot
with mance the decision to ride south of
course jon is stabbed pretty bad but
there's strong evidence he'll be
resurrected by Melisandre who in the
show meets Arya and tells her they'll
meet again anyway maybe the faceless men
as worshippers of death disapprove of
Jon's resurrection and send aya to have
him killed a second time maybe IO will
wear the face of Jeyne Poole who in the
books is used by the Bolton's as a fake
aya to marry ramsey so aya may impose
the person who impersonated her it's
implied that faceless men aren't allowed
to kill people whose names they know
though so our might only be sent to kill
John if snow goes by azor Ahai Oh King
Jonathan stark area in the first or
whatever but the point is imagine the
drama of aya being sent to kill John it
could be the big test of whether arya
truly is no one could she bring herself
to kill her beloved brother the last of
her family that she knows of could she
truly let go of her identity as aya the
answer is probably no the currently man
says he doesn't think I you can become
no one that beneath all her names all
her identities there's still some ayah
there and it looks like he's Riot ayah
says as much herself she doesn't kill
for the many-faced God she kills to
avenge her friends and family and she
keeps needle try as she might she cannot
rid herself of aya can't become no one
so will she go back to being Arya what's
left to go back to ayahs home is gone
her parents dead and all her brothers
slain but John + tree boy bran and
unicorn Island Rickon and what's even
left of Arya
she's been horseface underfoot hairy
lumpy head lumpy face weasel nan squab
salty cat blind Beth the ugly little
girl mercy and each one has worn away at
her identity like the kindly man says
there is an ayah beneath all this but
this ayah is so broken she says she has
a hole inside her where her heart had
been that the hole will never feel any
better
aya is extremely tough and adaptable but
she's an 11 year old girl her family and
friends have been butchered before her
she sent murder and worse at Harrenhal
her best friend is the worst [ __ ] in the
Seven Kingdoms and she joins a literal
death cult she's deeply traumatized part
of why she tries to forget her life as
ayah is to dissociate from her suffering
after all she's been through aya can
hardly function like a person let alone
become the noble lady she never wanted
to be in the first place she can't trust
she can't relax all she knows is killing
and survival
she can't return to a normal life as aya
Stark
but she can't truly be no one either who
or what can she be aya is connected to
the old gods the nameless faceless gods
of the Greenwood she feels them guiding
her steps and when she prays to them in
clashes she hears a response she hears
her father's voice repeating when the
snows fall and the white winds blow the
lone wolf dies but the pack survives she
is reminded that she has the wolf blood
and she hears a great pack of wolves
call in to her aya is closely associated
with wolves throughout the series people
call her a wolf girl and a wolf [ __ ]
she sees wolf she hears will she house
the wolves and they howl back she thinks
of herself as a wolf
in fact aya is a walk someone who enters
the minds of animals like bran enters
summer she walks a couple of cats in
Braavos but mostly bugs her dire wolf
Nymeria she has wolf dreams meaning
while she sleeps her mind becomes one
with
Nymeria who now leads a great pack of
hundreds of man killing wolves around
the Riverlands are your wolf dreams all
the time more and more as the series
goes on and this forms a new identity
different tire and different to no one
she calls herself of the night wolf and
this is what she wants iö wishes and
prays to be made into a wolf and there
actually is a way that could happen we
know from the prologue of dance that
when a warg like iodized they may live a
second life by having their spirit leave
their body and become one with their
animal if iodized her spirit could
become one with Nymeria there's plenty
of foreshadowing that are made I nedd
compares aya to her aunt Lyanna who had
the wolf blood was beautiful and willful
and dead before her time John jokes that
after winter they will find Aya's body
with a needle still locked tight between
her frozen fingers and we've heard over
and over from aya and others that Valar
morghulis
all men must die George our Martin has
said that the ending of his series will
be bittersweet the death of aya would be
tragic but it would be sweet in that
ayah would finally have what she's
wanted all this time because in one
sense our story is about a killers quest
to take revenge on evil men but it's
also the story of a kid trying to find a
family what I ëcause a pack this is what
I has been chasing all this time it's
why she sticks with hot pie and Gendry
even when she'd be safer alone while she
stays with the Hound when he murdered
her friend maybe even while she joins
the faceless men there's no denying that
ayah is a killer but she also wants a
pack at least as much as she wants blood
and becoming Nymeria could give her both
she'd be swift and strong running down
her prey with her pack at her heels are
you dying and becoming Nymeria would
fulfill Ned's words of the lone wolf
dying but the packs of Ivan it would
solve AI is identity crisis by becoming
the night wolf rather than aya or no one
and it would give a beautiful
bittersweet ending to a story of loss of
identity and death
a working title for the final
installment of the series was a time for
wolves you can almost see the epilogue
the closing moment of the series after
all the misery
maybe we'll see aya as a dire wolf
running with her pack across the snow so
feel free to comment what you think will
happen to aya and subscribe to all chip
decks for more videos on Game of Thrones
and more thanks
you